here we go
all right hello everyone welcome to
today's career webinar on personal
branding i'm meera singh ravath your
career coach
i'm accompanied today by my colleague
jackie
she's usually from london uk but today
she's out of her country so thank you
jackie very much to be my support
partner i know you have
gone through a lot of challenges to be
able to get online
she'll be assisting um us at the back
end and moderating the chat for us
so moving on on slide number two
this is the most interesting part for me
at least because this also gives me an
insight into who all are there on the
webinar
so before we begin let's get to know
each other it will be lovely if all of
you can type your name
and the nanodegree that you are pursuing
um
and if possible your location so that
everyone gets to know each other
and can connect later directly i always
encourage
all my students to visit the student hub
on career hotline chat room
every day and leverage from the q a that
are being asked there
and also connect and network with the
other students so please go ahead
and type out your details in the chat
box
this will help all of you to know how
many of these students are actually
uh you know sharing the same nano degree
like you
and then it will be easy for you to
connect with them share information
share knowledge you can even partner for
the projects that each one of you are
doing
many times to upload the projects in
your github you need some partners you
know to do open source projects
so this is a very good opportunity for
all of you to know uh if there are
similar
uh students doing similar nanodegrees
and go ahead and connect with as many as
you want even if they don't share your
nano degree you can still share ideas
and you can still share strategies
you can still share information about
you know how each one of you is in a
different phase of career
and help each other out so go ahead and
type out your name nanodegree and
location all right we move on now to
slide number three
now a quick introduction about me i'm
current currently located out of india
and i have close to two and a half
decades of work experience
and senior leadership roles for large
multinational firms
and their captives focus on bfsi
sorry somebody is trying to say
something
you can type in the chat if somebody
needs to say something please
all right so i'm culturally astute with
extensive experience in bringing
together global stakeholders
i'm known for mentoring coaching and
developing high performance teams
with diverse capabilities i have
consistently nurtured teams and
developed leaders across my tenure
at various organizations i'm also a
certified behavior and personality
assessor
specialized in disk assessment tools and
i specialize in career strategy
interviewing skills
and job search so welcome once again to
this webinar on importance of group
interviews
and uh how to ace them moving on to next
slide slide number four
what are our key takeaways today and
what can we expect to gather from this
webinar today
so here is a list of things which is
self-readable
we will understand what our group
interviews what are the different types
of group interviews
your assessment what are you being
assessed on you will come to know that
what are the tips that can help you to
answer group interview questions
the do's and the don'ts and the tasks
and the activities and of course the
sample interview questions
moving on to the next slide that's the
agenda slide it's very much a mirror of
our key takeaways so without investing
more time on this slide
we will quickly move on to the first
agenda item slide and then the content
slide
slide number seven what is
group interview this is the first agenda
item for today
so group interviews refer to a type of
interview
where more than two people are involved
it can mean
that a number of candidates are
interviewed together at the same time
known as candidate group interview or
that one candidate is interviewed by
more different department
representatives
at the same time so group interviews are
used by a whole host of employers
from investment banks and recruitment
companies to retailers and advertising
agencies
they might be the first stage of the
recruitment process or they might form
part of an assessment center by group
interviews
we mean a situation where you are
interviewed
alongside a group of other candidates
who are probably applying
to the same role as you for situations
where you are interviewed by a group of
the company's employees
check out the panel interview uh slide
on the next which is going to come up so
a group interview can come in many
guises
for instance it might involve giving a
presentation about the company and the
role
you might be discussing a topic with the
other candidates such as a hypothetical
work situation
or you might be given a task to complete
as a team so all in all a group
interview is where a group of people can
be interviewing you or you may be
interviewed
um alongside with other people so moving
on it's full
time so let's get on with the poll and
i'm going to launch the poll for you
this is an this is anonymous so you guys
don't have to
uh worry what answer you are giving go
ahead and please
uh choose your answers this is just to
get a sense check of you know
how much do we think we know and how
much can we gain
so and we won't know who's typing what
answers so it's perfectly fine
i guess uh there are just a few more
people who are just about to answer
and uh i think we are almost done 100
voting done fantastic so i'm going to
end the poll now and i hope i'll be able
to put it up
the results are 40 percent say yes
they have experienced a group interview
and 60 percent say
uh that they haven't experienced
is everyone able to see the results on
the screen
if yes then please type yes on the chat
okay perfect
so we have a great mix 60 of the
audience have not been able to
experience a group interview so it's a
great thing now for you guys
to uh actually uh learn what our group
interviews so let's get going moving on
to the next slide
on to slide number 10 styles
yup all right
moving on to slide number 10 types of
group interviews
your experience and the strategies you
will need
will depend on the type of group
interview
you will attend will you be talking to
multiple representatives of the same
company
or will you be competing against several
candidates for the same role
so here are two group interview types
you can expect
as we can see on the slide there are
three types of group interviews
first is the group interview second is
the panel interview
and third is meet the team interview so
we let's start with group interview
in group interview multiple candidates
are interviewed at the same time by one
interviewer typically
the hiring manager in this scenario you
and the other candidates would be
interviewed together in a group
sometimes a group interview combines
both types of interviews
you might be interviewed in a group by a
panel of interviewers
all right now we move to the next a
panel interview
a panel interview is one in which you
the interviewee
are brought in to the interview with a
group of individuals
from the company you are the sole focus
of the
interview and the interviewers spend the
time
asking you questions and getting to know
you
a panel interview might include
potential co-workers
and professional peers as well as
managers
and next level individuals a
group interview on the other hand is
where you are interviewed alongside
several other potential candidates for
the same position
now the third type what is a meet the
team interview
the meet the team interview typically
follows the group interview and
potentially
additional one-on-one interviews meet
the team interviews are usually the
final interview before hiring a
candidate
in other words if you are invited to
meet the team
the organization is likely ready to hire
you
and wants to make sure that you fit in
with the rest of the team before
they do so so moving on to the agenda
slide and then the
next slide which is poll we are on slide
number 12
and it is poll time again i'm going to
launch this poll now for everybody to be
able to take it
and uh let's go to the second poll for
today
launching the poll now it's anonymous go
ahead
make your pick let's see what we have
all right i can see the numbers rolling
in
excellent some people were super quick
in the first three seconds they answered
it so yeah
and i can clearly see the choice coming
out out of the seven
eight options that we have on the screen
here
interesting all right we are seeing the
numbers changing
and we are 100 percent there all right
so i'm going to end the poll now and i'm
going to put up the screen
uh the results and please type yes if
you can see the results
so we can see an interesting very very
interesting mix on this particular poll
48 percent which is almost like 50
percent of the audience say that
all of the above industries are known to
use group interviews
and then of course we have five percent
who think it's retail
10 percent who thinks it's technology
another tenant service another fine
manufacturing
and so on and so forth so the highest
percentage is
all of the about and you are absolutely
right it's all of the above
all right so we move on now to our next
slide
which is um the actual content slide
slide number 13
where and why are group interviews used
so let's start with the where's first
group interviews are often done
for frontline jobs like those in retail
customer service food service because
these roles rely on a candidate's
ability
to solve problems keep calm and think
fast all while wearing a smile it does
not mean
that group interviews are limited to
only these roles
as most of the organizations are now
able to relate
to its benefits typical businesses that
use
group interviews include technology
organizations i'm myself from a
technology organization so i can vouch
for it
usually when recruiting in business
development roles
or sales a typical interview will
include a presentation delivered by the
company
followed by a group activity small group
presentations
and then individual interviews this is
what usually happens in a technology
organization when they do group
interviews the next type of
industry that is very well known to do
group interviews is high street
retailers
specifically used in managerial training
programs
the group interview may include smaller
group based activities and presentations
followed by an individual interview
the third type of industry which majorly
uses this is investment and finance
firms
again i'm a part of that industry as
well group interviews are usually based
around a controversial subject
so that interviewers can assess
how candidates deal with conflict
so these are some of the industries but
not limiting to them
alone we move on to the next slide slide
number 14
still on the same topic here we discuss
the why of the group interviews why do
organizations use group interview
so a few top of mind reasons for group
interviews are
save time and gain face time with a
wider pool of candidates
second talent identification third
direct comparisons an increasing number
of companies
are using group interviews to screen job
applicants this change could be
attributed to the desire to reduce
turnover and the fact that teamwork is
becoming more critical in the workplace
more employers are starting to prefer
the setup because
it's cost effective it's cheaper and
faster
after all to interview 10 people at once
then it is to talk to them individually
and since
applicants will need to interact with
others during the discussion
it also gives employers a preview of how
applicants react in an environment that
tests their communication leadership
and teamwork skills so hiring managers
want to see not only
how you do on your own but how you do
when you
are paired with those around you
and how well you can work together
so they look for things like are you a
team player
or are you just looking for an
opportunity
to sabotage the other interviewees
second are you a leader or are you a
follower
third can you problem solve with others
or you are a part of the problem itself
next they try to see are you comfortable
taking directions from someone else
or are you the one who has to constantly
be in charge no matter what
one more example what they are looking
for is can you stand out from the other
job seekers in the room and
differentiate yourself
enough to showcase who you are
without dominating the interview and
standing out
for all the wrong reasons the quickest
way
to make sure you leave a lasting
positive impression
on your hiring manager and interview
team
requires you to first master the art
of the group interview before you even
walk through that door
a lot of times group interviews are used
for positions
that include stakeholder and service
components
and interactions with large number of
clients or the public
so interpersonal and communication
skills are put to test over here
not only are you answering questions you
are
also demonstrating through your actions
exactly what
you are going to be like to work with
to check if candidates have the ability
to think
fast on their feet keep their cool and
solve problems
which is why you need to be sure you're
more than ready
to tackle this sort of interview in a
professional way
moving on to next slide which is agenda
slide number 15
so before that we will take a poll which
is on slide number 16.
so here is the next poll and i'm going
to put it up for everybody to take it
it's anonymous feel free to pick up your
answers we are on poll number three
and this poll is about what do employers
assess in a group interview we have
multiple options
feel free to choose whichever you like
and
i can see the numbers growing and people
are choosing their options
i'm sure it's based either out of your
experience or based out of whatever you
have read or heard about them
and almost uh each one of you is correct
in your own way
it's an interesting uh result that i can
see
i'm just waiting for that last two
percent of people to respond and we will
be through
we'll give them probably just 10 more
seconds
and i'll put up the results on the
screen for you guys to see all right we
have hundred percent and i'm going to
now put up the
results on the screen please type yes if
you can see
interesting so we find 71 percent of the
participants saying all of the above
are assessed in a group interview which
is soft skills transferable skills
behavioral skills technical skills and
all of the above
we have 19 percent saying soft skills
five persons
think transferable skills and five
percent same tech skills
the uh the popular answer is all of the
above and i would like to go with that
all right so we move on with our
presentation
and we move to the next slide which is
slide number 17
now we will answer what you will be
assessed on
so group interviews are not a time
to kick back and relax you are still
very much in the spotlight
most companies will have a list of
skills that they are looking for
evidence of during the interview you can
usually get a sense of the kind of
attributes they want in an employee from
the company website
and the job description otherwise here
are some of the key skills they might be
looking for which is also there on the
slide
teamwork communication skills
negotiation skills
assertiveness and confidence ability to
take and give criticism
leadership skills moving on to the next
slide
the topic continues what you will be
assessed on so let's explore this a
little more in detail
group interviewers look for the same
things
that other interviewers look for they
want to see a
strong candidate who knows how to work
well
with others and behave properly and
competently in a work environment so
what are the specific things that group
interviewers scrutinize
here it is your appearance
really appearance you must be wondering
oh yes
in appearance what is it that they look
for attire
hygiene and anything else that relates
to your physical form will be judged
if you wear too much makeup or cologne
at least
one of the interviewers will notice if
you forgot to put on deodorant or match
your socks
at least one of the interviewers will
notice so
dress well for the interview second your
presentation skills
interviewers will be paying special
attention
to how you present yourself do you
slouch
do you fidget do you make eye contact
when you converse
did you remember to shake hands with
everyone in the room
be aware of your body language and what
it says about you during an interview
third the communication skills no matter
what
type of job you are applying for you
will need
to be able to communicate properly
so specific skills that group
interviewers look for is your ability to
listen
follow instructions and get your ideas
across
next your interest level from the time
the interview starts
until it ends interviewers will be
trying to assess
how interested you are in the job you
are applying for
if you seem bored and disengaged
during the interview you will probably
be passed by by someone
else so let's move on to next slide
slide number 19
the new agenda item and the slide 20 has
the content
so the agenda item tips to answer
group interview questions we are on
slide number 20.
here are five group interview tips that
will
ensure that you stand out from the other
candidates
and walk out of the interview room as
the front runner for the
job i think there is one of us
who has not muted the microphone
i think it's loud swelling so loads if
you can please put your phone on mute
that will be helpful
as we are able to hear some of the
noises
i can even see skyler which is not on
mute
so maybe one of the two uh please put
your phone on mutes
all right so tips to answer interview
questions
first one get to know your fellow
interviewees
in most cases you will share a waiting
room with the other candidates
that you will be interviewing with so
don't just sit there
sharing competitive glances their way as
if you were just about to compete
against them like a gladiator
okay walk up to each one
and shake their hand ask everyone their
name and more importantly
remember them all for your interview
does anyone stand out does anyone's
energy indicate that they might have
leadership qualities
try and get a feel for the type of
person each candidate
is the reason for this little exercise
will be clear once you get into the room
having a bit of background on each
person
will make any group activities a little
easier
for one you have broken the eyes meaning
basic interactions will be that much
easier
two in approaching each candidate you
have almost
marked your territory as a potential
leader of the group
and finally as you emerge as the leader
and start addressing everyone by name
hiring managers will be impressed with
the way
you take ownership of the group and your
attention to detail
moving on to the next slide slide number
we are on the same topic tips to answer
group interview questions
now we are on the second tip pretend you
are the leader
continuing the tip from the first slide
you want to start acting like the leader
of the group
as soon as you walk into the room don't
wait for someone else to take the
leadership role in any group activities
in almost every situation a natural
leader will emerge
and more often than not this person will
jump to the top of the pile in the eyes
of the hiring managers
you want no wait you need to be this
person
but one small caveat you don't want it
to appear
forced and more importantly
you don't want to come off as a
bossypants
the best way to naturally reflect
leadership
is to support your fellow interviewees
in any team activities and to vocalize
your opinions
so that they are clear and concise which
leads us to our next step
third tip is use your outside voice
inside
what does it mean okay so this does not
mean that you should scream at the
hiring manager
or start drowning out the other
interviewees
or cut them off when they are speaking
no no no
what it means is that you should project
your voice
and speak confidently and avoid mumbling
or any other meek behaviors
remember your job is to stand out from
the crowd
and make sure that everything you say is
heard loud and clear
in the first step you need is the first
step you need to take to ensure this
will happen
moving on to the next slide tip number
four
be memorable not far not for the wrong
reasons
so what does it mean at the end of the
day
you want the hiring manager or managers
to remember you long after the interview
is finished
here are some examples of the great
impression
that good candidates leave behind to be
remembered by
so you know some of the statements that
i recall from my
um experience of group interviews once
the group interview is gone and you know
we all the company people are sitting
there
and these are the kind of statements
which come out wow
that guy really brought the group
together to complete the exercise we
gave them
i really appreciated the eye contact
that so and so maintained with me
throughout the interview
it really projected attentiveness and
confidence
another type of example one of the
interviewers experienced
i can really see this person being a
part of my team
any of these responses would mean
that you have done a good job in your
group interview
this is what you're going for what you
are not going for
however are responses like you don't
want somebody to talk behind your back
with these statements
for example that one applicant kept
cutting off the other applicants when
they were speaking
it was extremely annoying and very rude
second example
that you don't want to be remembered for
i don't have much to say about
miss so-and-so because she was nearly
invisible for the entire interview
she really did not contribute much to
the group exercise
another negative example i could never
work with that person
his energy was overbearing and i don't
think he has much respect for authority
as you can see a much different story
so the point is you want to be memorable
you just don't want to be remembered for
the wrong reasons you want to be
remembered for the right reasons
tip number five don't forget your
manners
manners seriously yes
it seems simple but you won't believe
how many candidates get into the
interview room and
don't forget to use please and thank you
or hold the door for other candidates to
enter the room
for the most part it's because of focus
you want to do a good job you have got
all of those
interview questions rolling inside your
head
there is a lot to deal with but don't
forget these
basics the last thing you're thinking
about is your manners but hear this
hiring managers are paying attention
they want to hire candidates that are
polite
gracious and considerate of others so
make sure
that you are the perfect lady or
gentleman
not just to the hiring manager but to
your fellow
interviewees as well if you are passed a
handout
say thank you if your group activity
requires grabbing a chair to sit in
grab two and give one to the candidate
next to you
and when you are made to made it to at
the end of the interview
and are about to run out of that door
and jump in the air
and click your heels together take a
minute
circle back to the hiring manager look
him
or her in the eye extend out your hand
and say thanks thank you and thank him
or her for her time it's a small gesture
but one that many interviewees forget to
do
and it's the last impression you will
leave with the hiring manager
so moving on it's poll time again and
probably this will be the last poll for
the
webinar today so i'm going to launch the
poll
it's anonymous feel free to choose
whatever answer you like
and here we go so the poll question is
what behaviors will tank your group
interviews
tank means what behaviors will probably
definitely give you
there's somebody who's not on mute you
could probably put your phone on mute
please
all right what behaviors will thank your
group interview
and we have the options dominating the
conversation
being aggressive listening well
including opinion of others being
aggressive
not paying attention so this
is a little tricky one so i'll give a
clue to some of you guys
not all the answers may be right and not
all the answers may be wrong
so do read the options carefully
which behavior will be enabler
and which behavior will be a disabler
so out of these six behaviors
which are the positive behaviors that
you definitely must have
so obviously you will not choose them
because they are going to help you
and which are the behaviors which are
going to
thank you or which are going to fail you
which are the disablers
all right so i can see some people still
thinking that's good that's good
i'm once again saying there are some
enablers
and there are some disablers okay so we
do
need some of these behaviors
all right so there definitely are some
behaviors listed over here
which we do require in group interview
to create positive impression all right
so we are almost there i can just see
two percent of people waiting to answer
maybe they are thinking very
hard or somebody has probably left the
screen i'm not sure which one of it is
true
but i'll give it another 10 seconds
so anyone who has not yet answered feel
free to take the poll please
it's very interesting question and you
may learn something new
all right uh
[Music]
so whoever has posted a question
probably jackie if she has the time she
will answer or you can ask the question
at the end of the session
where there will be a dedicated time for
q a
so i'm going to end the poll now and i'm
going to share the results please type
yes if you're able to see
now don't you think this is very very
interesting
i mentioned that there are some positive
behaviors listed here
which definitely cannot be the answer to
this poll
so there are two positive uh
uh behaviors here first is listening
well
and second is including opinions of
others
these two are positive behaviors and in
a group interview
or in a group activity or in a work
environment
unless we don't listen well how will we
be able to
actually give a solution or contribute
so if we have listen and half do we will
never find a solution
so whoever has uh picked up these two
answers i would like to just explain to
them
that listening well and including
opinion of others is a positive behavior
irrespective whether it is a group
interview or not a group interview
and we all should have that rest all of
you are absolutely right
rest all the behaviors are disablers
dominating the conversation being
aggressive
uh oh surprisingly being aggressive has
come out twice maybe a typo error
not paying attention all right this was
an interesting one
moving on now to our presentation
the next slide is slide number 24.
uh this is agenda slide so we will go to
the next slide
the do's and don'ts of group interviews
so let's start with the do's first
arrive early when you are
competing against a number of other
candidates
it is essential you make the most of
every opportunity to stand out
and not be remembered for the wrong
reasons aside from
being punctual and courteous arriving
ahead of schedule has another unique
advantage in this situation
at a group interview you can expect to
be monitored from the moment you enter
the building
so the earlier you arrive the longer you
have to impress
it allows you to interact with other
candidates
in the less formal setting showing off
your social skills
however bear in mind that there is
such a thing as arriving too early
getting there before the security guard
will not win you
any bonus points second be inclusive
this is what was there in the poll we
have to include the opinions of everyone
so being inclusive is a positive
behavior
and it's a dose part of the do's include
everyone
although your leadership skills are
being assessed
do not be tempted to go overboard one of
the most
important facets of leadership is
the ability to ensure everyone's
opinions are heard
not just voicing your own if there is an
introvert in the group getting them
involved in the task
and encouraging them to participate will
win you
major points both with your fellow
candidates
and with your interviewers third prepare
questions if you have prepared for your
interview correctly you should have
carried out plenty of research about the
company
what the company does and their position
within the market
always use this to your advantage during
the obligatory
any other questions position portion of
the
interview however if you genuinely
cannot think of anything to bring up for
the discussion don't force it
asking an irrelevant question just for
the sake of
asking one is more transparent than you
think
so if you don't have a question don't
force it
next point is remember the ice breaker
before any of the actual tasks begin
you will almost always be asked
to provide some sort of introduction for
yourself
or some sort of introduction for someone
else in the group
to avoid embarrassing situations
always prepare your answer beforehand
your intro need not be long provided
it's pertinent and engaging
the next point is listen more than you
talk
so do listen of course being able to
share your ideas and opinions and talk
confidently in a room full of people
are important skills to have but
people often forget the importance and
attractiveness
of a listener as well listening is an
art
not everybody is capable of listening
there is a difference between hearing
and listening
i go to b schools to as a guest lecturer
on persuasive communication and there i
explain the difference between hearing
and listening it's the listening which
makes you a great persuasive
communicator
so listening is an is a skill and it's
an
art which takes time to hone whatever
job you are going for you will need to
have good listening skills
whether that's listening to instructions
so you can perform a task correctly
or listening to customers or
listening to feedback and advice from
your manager
in a group interview you should take the
time to show your good listening skills
this does not just mean to sit back in
silence
be an active listener lean in
and look at the person who's making a
point nod your head at them
in agreement or encouragement make eye
contact with them
to show your confidence this will not
go unnoticed and will make sure
you tick another box on the observers
list there will always be somebody
observing
next tip is answer first every now and
then
to stand out you either have to give the
best answer
or be the first one to share your
thoughts correct
since it is impossible to guarantee that
you will always have the best answer in
a group setup
it will be easier to stand out if you
are the first to answer the question
of course you should only do this once
in a while
so it does not look like you're blocking
out other
applicants so answer first every now and
then
next tip is conduct due diligence on
interviewers this applies to both types
of group interviews
but it's specifically important in a
group setup in a panel setup because
knowing the interviewer's position will
help you understand their point of view
when it comes to the group interview
questions they
what they ask so
what do you have to look for when you
have to collect the information
interviewer's full name his title or
position at the company
anything to break the ice why they are
hiring
if possible their educational background
while you may not get a chance to
research the panel members before the
group interview
especially if the group interview was a
surprise
if you listen closely while the panel
members are being
introduced you can learn a lot about
each other
remember those college and university
days when the professor is teaching and
we all are having our mobile phones in
our hand below the desk and we are
trying to google and find out more
you can put that skill to use when the
panel members are being introduced and
find information about them without
being noticed
what is the next do be friendly but
be true to your convictions the tendency
to go along with the crowd is strong in
any group setup
with friends and family people often
keep the status quo and avoid arguments
and the same applies in the workplace
only at work employers look for people
who don't shy away from arguments
because
that is a necessary trait for leadership
so do not hesitate to rock the boat in
group interviews
if you believe in your answer
and if you have a solid argument
you may not be applying for a leadership
role but this is a good way to stand
out in a discussion that people tend to
agree
with the most popular opinion if you are
afraid of coming on too strong
frame your counter argument as a
question
for instance instead of claiming the
group's consensus on a sales strategy
is wrong instead of that ask
did this sales tactic always work for
you previously
so you're not challenging but you're
questioning
there is a difference between
challenging and questioning
it is easier to make the group question
their opinion
first then it is to sell them
that they are wrong outright we are not
here to prove anybody wrong we are only
trying to have
another opinion correct the next do is
what
be confident in your body language
and voice group interviews favor the
charismatic and confident
so keep your chin up your back relaxed
and smile when you answer
keep your voice clear and level don't
let it trail off in the middle of
answering
because that'll just give other
applicants a chance to interrupt you
next step which is last on the slide
greet
both interviewers and candidates
individually
arrive at the venue early then introduce
yourself to the interviewer
and everyone else participating yes
this includes other applicants this not
only breaks the eyes it's also a good
way to get everyone's name
so you can use it when you address them
during the
interview or an activity you might think
addressing another applicant by name
isn't important but to the interviewer
who is
observing this shows that you have got
good people skills
so moving on to the next slide slide
number 26
now we will see what are the don'ts of
the group interview
what are the things that we should not
be demonstrating and displaying
the first one don't be fake it may be a
cliche
but sometimes the best advice is just to
be yourself
chances are your interviewers will be
experienced in group situations
and therefore adapt in detecting when
someone is overdoing it
trying too hard to stand out is not
going to make you many friends
especially amongst your assessors so
always try to be as genuine as possible
see also laughter unless you are going
for a job as a
pantomime villain leave your over
exuberant chuckles and
other behaviors at the door second
do not talk over people this is one of
the common
most common mistakes of the group
interview try hard
when the competitive nature of the
interview kicks in
it can be tempting to increase the
volume
to get your point across however
whatever role you are applying for you
should never
underestimate the importance of teamwork
remember the wisest people don't
always speak the loudest but they always
make their voices
heard so always try to think before you
speak
next do not get lost in the group
there is a fine balance between this
point and the next point
it is highly likely that whether genuine
or not one or two people in the group
will try and take control
if and when this happens don't let
yourself be intimidated or overwhelmed
instead use them to your advantage
if you do not agree with their points
feel free to be controversial
and offer your own opinion then open up
the discussion to the group
a wise man once said the tallest
tree catches the most wind
the tallest tree catches the most
wind think about it okay
the next point do not become too
informal
as in any other interview situation
there is a certain etiquette for group
interviews
which should always be adhered to it's
fine to appear comfortable
and relaxed in some instances for
example
taking your coat or scarf mittens off is
perfectly acceptable
and indeed can be a particular you know
bug bear for other recruiters if it is
left on
but do not however use this
as an excuse to leave your manners at
the door
number one do not refer to your
interviewers
or co-interviewees as mate
your interviewers are not your friends
number two
do not swear being controversial is
okay as long as you have a well
articulated polite and appropriate
argument
being rude vulgar or offensive is
however
definitely a big no-no number three
avoid discussing any excesses you might
enjoy
in your own time yeah
perhaps save that particular tale for
another day week or lifetime
it's unlikely to impress okay
next do not lose concentration
finally it is essential to maintain
maximum concentration at all times
take notes keep eye contact at an
acceptable and socially acceptable level
smile nod and generally try and look
enthusiastic and engage throughout
avoid spending your time staring off
into the space
or worse checking your phone during
proceedings
the same also applies to doodling if you
cannot listen to the introductory
presentation
without practicing your inner picasso
you probably won't be invited back
anytime soon
so be careful next and the last point on
the slide
do not view everyone as competition
this sounds silly because of course the
other candidates are your competition
but if you focus on this too much you
are only going to
appear aggressive and rude you need to
use the other candidates to show you are
a good team player
and can correctly interact with people
so
don't talk over them don't shut them
down
or don't even look as if you are sizing
them up
working with them instead of against
them will work
far better in your favor moving on to
the next slide slide number 27
which is the agenda slide so we will
move on to the next slide
slide number 28 a few popular group
interview tasks and activities all right
so now here i have given examples
i'll quickly read through them in the
interest of the time because i want to
give some time
to all of you for questions and answers
we did start
with a delay of five minutes so we will
factor that in as an additional time
so now we are on slide number 28 first
example
let's say these are some of the examples
of tasks and
activities in this group interview task
you will be given a brief based on a
scenario
you are likely to face as an employee of
the company
you are interviewing for the brief will
outline certain problems
which you along with your fellow group
interviewees
will be required to solve case study
interview activities are designed to
test your ability
to work as part of a team as well as
your leadership and problem solving
skills
so what are the tips for conquering the
case study activity
treat your competitors as colleagues
take the lead
but don't talk over people show good
leadership
by including any introverts research the
company
before you attend the interview remember
you are
being watched the interviewer is not
just interested in the solutions
they are interested in how you worked
together
to find the solution moving to next
slide
and to the next activity example two the
role play
one of the most dreaded group interview
activities has to be the role play
this group interview activity places you
in a position
you are likely to face in your
prospective role
such as chairing a meeting managing a
team or dealing with a customer
and it tests your ability to perform
well in it
here are some interview here the
interviewer may be assessing a
wide range of skills for example
leadership qualities
ability to provide good customer service
problem solving under pressure
so what are the tips that you can use
for role play read the brief carefully
ask questions to get an idea of the
bigger picture
actually listen to the answers structure
your approach to the exercise but remain
flexible
use appropriate body language and eye
contact be yourself and be confident
all right now
we move on to the next slide which is
group interview tasks and activities
continued the last activity the
practical task
group interviews commonly include a
practical task requiring the
interviewees to work together to solve a
problem
the practical task may or may not be
relevant to the job
for example candidates may be asked to
build the highest structure with the
least amount of bricks
or something similar yes you might
actually get to play with lego
during your interview but basically
you're being tested on your ability to
communicate and work as a part of the
team
so here are the tips for a successful
practical task activity
contribute your ideas don't get lost in
the group
listen to others and value their ideas
too
remain professional in how you
communicate with other candidates
find an opportunity to take the lead but
don't steamroll
keep focused it may be a fun task but
you
are there to impress now we move on to
sample group
interview questions okay
now i have i am going to read only uh
the questions uh because these are all
very self
understanding self-descriptive content
on the slides
so probably i'll read one or two and we
will move on to q a
in the interest of time so we are on
slide number 32.
the most likely group interview question
how
would your colleague describe you what
is it that they want to know
hiring managers ask this question to
measure
your level of self-perception compare
your answers to what your references
have said
and predict how well you would fit into
their company culture
right next question how would you
describe yourself
see first they are asking you how would
your colleagues describe you
the next question they are asking you
how would you describe yourself
moving on to the next slide slide number
next popular question why do you want
this job
what interested you in our company
moving on to the next slide slide number
how can your skills and experiences
further our company's mission
don't be taken away with this what they
really want to know is
why should we hire you please read the
content on the slides
this will come up on the youtube and all
of you who have registered for the
webinar
will get a link of it the next question
on the same slide is
how do you work in a team moving on to
the next slide slide number 35
describe your career history and future
goals
in 30 seconds do you know what they want
to know you are being assessed on your
achievements your foresight your
planning and your aspirations
the next popular question what made this
team work successfully this is after the
tasks and
activities are completed these kind of
questions are asked
moving on to the next slide slide number
36 the question number nine
what would you hire who would you hire
from your group and why
now this is a big question what is it
that they want to know
part of being a valuable team member
is being willing to acknowledge the
contributions of your peers
okay so read the content on this slide
later on
well next question what was your
personal contribution to the team's
performance
and now we will go to the last slide
slide number 37
question number 11 why did this team
struggle to accomplish the objective
and how did you deal with the stress
created
by meeting the challenges so what they
want to know in the last question
how do you handle stress it's a very
common interview question
okay and they want to judge whether you
will be able to cope with the pace and
demands
of their workplace and now we come to
the next slide which is take away
resource links
i'm going to copy paste the links for
all of you over here on the chat
this will also be uploaded in the even
descriptions
so do not worry if any one of you has
not been able
to pick up the resource links from the
chat
anyone who wishes to pick up here it is
on the chat feel free to copy paste and
save them
these are resource links which are great
articles which will help you
to understand group interviews more in
detail moving on now
to the credits and of course the q a
so jackie if we can move on to the q a
that will be helpful
here we are to the most popular section
and we will have five to 10 minutes on
this
so now over to you guys the floor is on
to open to you
feel free to ask questions and jackie if
there have been questions earlier in the
chat that you have noticed
feel free to bring them up now and if
any one of you has written a question
earlier which has gone away in the chat
please type it again
yeah i do see leo has mentioned a
question
showing leadership behavior is
recommended also for
operational positions absolutely leo
leadership skills are required for
all the positions because that
differentiates you from the rest of the
team
how do you think you get promotions how
do you think you get noticed
how do you think you get visibility
there will always be leaders
and there will always be followers so
right from the fresher badge
to the mid-level management to the
senior management
if you notice there will always be
somebody who's ahead of the team
who the other people follow so showing
leadership behavior
is always a positive sign we most of the
people are born with it
but it is also a skill that can be
acquired
all right we have a question from ludes
which says can you place the resource
links on the screen again
all right here you go i have pasted it
again for you
so jackie has said uh jackie
has mentioned due to covert 19 we will
be doing a lot of virtual interviews
especially in the us
and in il we were hit hard
how to stand out on video okay that's
the question
how to stand out on video so you will
have to definitely practice some video
tips
the best and the easiest and the
simplest
tip on video interviews is prepare the
answers
for the top five popular tech and
non-tech questions
practice the questions record yourself
on your laptop
and observe both your content
and your body language this is a sure
short way
of being confident of finding your blind
spots
and preparing yourself to put your best
foot forward
so the best tip for video interview is
to practice
and record your answers ahead of the
interview
i hope that helps and if you have to
cover up
for your nervousness i'll give you a
very
simple hack keep a glass of water
or a sipper nobody will kill you to pick
up the sipper and have a sip of water
it gives you those 10 seconds to recover
from the nervousness
or it gives you those 10 seconds where
you can actually think about the answer
in your mind
without coming across as being lost okay
so that's a good hack for the video
interviews
i see quang asking a question in a group
interview it is very common that
everyone would try to be the leader
and just talk non-stop and it's very
hard
to add your opinions how should we
handle that
so quang i did cover that in the slides
earlier
when the video recording comes up on the
youtube you may want to go through the
slides once again
but as i said there are observers
in each interviewer when people are
trying to talk over
other people that also is being observed
i have experienced a great success
whenever people are trying to raise
their voice and trying not
allowing the other person to talk i
always put my hand
up and that is noticed by the
interviewers by the teams by everybody
just raise your hand and say
if i can be please heard i have an
opinion and mind you
everybody needs to show their best
behavior they cannot
not allow you to talk okay so
that's a good way of making your voice
heard if everybody is trying to talk
over you
it is not possible that if you are a
leader or if you have a leadership
skills
that everyone every time will be keeping
talking over you
if there are ten instances and if you
have been able to voice your opinion
three times it's more than enough
that's more than enough for an observer
to know you can talk
when you want to and when you have
something relevant to talk
it's not essential that every time we
will have something relevant to
contribute
right but when you have something
relevant and people are not allowing you
just raise your hand and say i have an
opinion which i think is different if i
can be heard
thank you ayush um i see a question
sometimes honest answers can be
uncomforting
how should such answers be given this is
a very debatable question
okay what is honest differs from person
to person
okay and how do you define honesty
and what are we calling about dishonesty
of the other people
so it will be quite challenging given
the limitation of the time for me to
answer this but i believe
integrity is a value which is highly
valued by all the organizations
if you think you're not agreeing to the
opinions of others
okay you have two options one
to be controversial as i mentioned in
the in the earlier slides
it's good to be controversial and put
the opinion further and
ask people to clarify
and second why do they think that your
opinion
is not popular that way you are
placing an opinion you are not pushing
out somebody
so be honest but be honest with attacked
challenging somebody and placing your
opinion are two different things
so being honest is absolutely a right
thing
but the way you communicate will decide
whether you will be
receptive by the other people or whether
you will be rejected
so it's a matter of communication skill
honesty is just a byproduct of how you
communicate
okay all right so i see rachel asking
thank you for your presentation do
companies not like
introvert people i am introvert and most
of the skills you mentioned
seem challenging what do you think can
be helpful to overcome my personality
how can an introvert person stand out
during an interview
now this will require definitely great
amount of practice
there are three p's rachel prepare
practice
perform so if you will google
given the context of the time frame we
have
i'm trying to give you some tips but you
can definitely book your one-on-one
coaching session with any of other
coaches
and we can definitely help you on how to
come out of your introvertness to a
level
where it is uh professionally an
acceptable trait
yeah but the quick tip that i can give
you is
three piece prepare practice and perform
ah leo it will be a pleasure to connect
with you all on linkedin fantastic
uh i'm sorry if my frame was freezing
maybe
we have to blame the technology and uh i
hope i'm back again
all right so i think
um i have covered for the five minutes
that we lost at the beginning of the
session
there were so many interesting questions
and thank you all of you you all have
been an amazing audience
and you all have asked me some real
questions which made me think on the
spot
and i hope i was able to help you guys
um i
i hope you found value in this session
you will get a link of this
and make sure that you go through the
articles and the links which have been
shared
on the on the webinar here today and
also in the even description
and all the best see you at the next uh
sessions
and um stay safe stay healthy
till we talk again all right
bye bye to all of you